in the last video we saw all sorts of
different types of isotopes of atoms
experiencing radioactive decay and
turning into other atoms or releasing
different types of particles but the
question is when does a a an atom or
nucleus decide to decay let's say i have
a bunch of let's say these are all atoms
i have a bunch of atoms here
and let's say we're talking about the
type of decay where an atom turns into
another atom so your proton number is
going to change your atomic number is
going to change so it could be it could
either be beta decay which would release
electrons from the neutrons in terms of
protons or maybe positron emission
turning protons into neutrons but that's
not what's relevant here let's say we
have a collection of atoms and normally
when we have anything of any any small
amount of any element we really have
huge amounts of atoms of that element
and we've talked about moles that you
know one gram of carbon 12
sorry 12 grams
12 grams of carbon 12
carbon 12
that has that's that has one mole of
carbon 12 in it one mole of carbon 12.
and what is one mole of carbon 12 that's
6.02 times 10 to the 23rd carbon 12
atoms this is this is a a a ginormous
number this is more than weakened that
my head can really grasp around how
large of a number this is so and this is
only when we have 12 grams 12 grams is
not a large mass for example uh one
kilogram is about two pounds so this is
about what one one i would say one
fiftieth of a pound if i'm doing but
this is this is not a lot of mass right
here and pounds is obviously force i
should well you get the idea on earth
this is not uh well anywhere mass is is
invariant this is not a tremendous
amount so with that said let's go back
to the question of how do we know if one
of these guys are going to decay in some
way and maybe not carbon 12 maybe we're
talking about carbon 14 or something how
do we know that they're going to decay
and the answer is you don't they all
have some probability of decaying at any
given moment for a certain type of
element or a certain type of isotope of
an element there's some probability that
one of them will decay that you know
maybe this guy'll decay the second
and then nothing happens for a long time
not a long time then all of a sudden two
more guys decay
two more to guys okay and so like
everything in chemistry and a lot of
what we're starting to deal with in
physics and quantum mechanics everything
is probabilistic i mean maybe if we
really got in detail on on the
configurations of the nucleus maybe we
could get a little bit better in terms
of our probabilities but we don't know
what's going on inside of the nucleus so
all we can do is ascribe some
probabilities to something reacting now
you could say okay what's the
probability of any given molecule
reacting in one second or you could
define it that way but we're used to
dealing things on the macro level on on
dealing with you know huge huge amounts
of of atoms so what we do is we come up
with terms that help us get our head
around this and one of those terms is
the term half-life
half-life
and let me
erase this stuff down here
so i have a description and we're going
to learn we're going to hopefully get an
intuition of what half-life means so i
wrote a a radio a decay reaction right
here where you have carbon-14
it decays into
nitrogen-14 and we could just a little
bit of review you go from six protons to
seven protons your mass change is the
same so one of the neutrons must have
turned into a proton and that is what
happens and it does that by releasing an
electron which is also called a beta
particle we could have written this as
-1 charge
relatively zero mass it does have some
mass but they write zero it's just kind
of notation so this is beta decay
beta decay this is just review
but the way we think about half-life is
people have studied
carbon and they said look if i
if i start off with 10 grams if i have
just a block of carbon
that's 10 grams
that's 10 grams if i weight carbon's
half carbon-14s half-life this is a
specific isotope of carbon remember
isotopes are they all isotopes that
there's carbon can come in
12 with an atomic mass number of 12 or
with 14 or i mean there are different
isotopes of different elements and they
all the the atomic number defines the
carbon because it has six protons
carbon-12 has six protons carbon-14 has
six protons but they have a different
number of neutrons so when you have the
same element varying in number of
neutrons that's an isotope so the
carbon-14
version or the this this isotope of
carbon let's say we start with 10 grams
if they say that it's half life is 5 740
years that means that if on year on day
one we start off with 10 grams of pure
carbon 14 after 5007
years half of this will have turned into
nitrogen 14 by beta decay and you might
say oh okay so
maybe let's see let me make nitrogen
magenta right there so you might say
okay maybe that half turns into nitrogen
and i've actually seen this drawn this
way in some chemistry classes or physics
classes and my major question is how
does this half know that it must turn
into nitrogen and how does this half
know that it must stay as carbon and the
answer is they don't know and it really
shouldn't be drawn this way
so let me redraw it so this is our
original
block
of
of of our carbon 14. what happens over
that
5740 years
is that probabilistically a bunch some
of these guys just start turning into
starting turning into
nitrogen
randomly at random points
at random points and over
5740 years you determine that there's a
50 percent chance that any one of these
carbon atoms will turn into a nitrogen
atom so they're over after 5 740 years
the half-life of carbon 50 chance that
any of the guys that are carbon will
turn to nitrogen so if you go back after
a half-life
half of the atoms
will now
will now be nitrogen so now you have
after one half-life so let's ignore this
so we started with this
all 10 grams were carbon 10 grams of c14
this is after one half-life one
half-life
and now we have
five grams of
c-14 and we have five grams
of
nitrogen-14
fair enough let's think about what
happens after another half-life
well we said that after during a
half-life
5740 years in the case of carbon-14
all different elements have different
half-life if they're radioactive
over
5740 years there's a 50 and if i look
just look at any one atom there's a 50
percent chance that it'll decay
so if we go to another half-life
if we go
another half-life from there i had 5
grams of carbon 14.
so let me
let me actually copy and paste this one
this is what i started with
now after another half-life ignore all
my little actually let me erase some of
this up here let me clean it up a little
bit
after what one half-life what happens
well still these this i now am left with
five grams of carbon-14 those 5 grams of
carbon 14
every one of those atoms still has over
the next 5 700 whatever that number was
5 740 years
after 5 740 years all of those once
again have a 50 chance and by the law of
not large numbers half of them will have
converted into nitrogen 14 so we'll have
even more conversion into nitrogen 14.
so now half of that 5 grams so now we're
only left with 2.5 grams
of
c14 and how much nitrogen 14 well we
have another two and a half went to
nitrogen so now we have seven and a half
grams
of nitrogen 14. and we could keep going
further and for
further future and go into the future
and we'll always be after every
half-life
5740 years we will have half of our of
the carbon that we started with but
we'll always have an infinitesimal
amount of carbon but let me ask you a
question let's say i'm just staring at
one carbon atom let's say i just have
this one carbon atom you know it's got
its nucleus with its it's c14 so it's
got its six protons
one two three four five six it's got its
eight
it's got its eight neutrons it's got its
it's got its six electrons one two three
four five six whatever
what is the probability what's going to
happen i won't let's not what's going to
happen after
let's go what's going to happen after
one second
well
i don't know it'll probably still be
carbon but there's some probability that
after one second it will have already
turned into
nitrogen 14. what's going to
what's going to happen after 1 billion
years
1 billion years
well after 1 billion years i'll say well
you know it'll probably have turned into
carbo nitrogen 14 at that point but i'm
not sure this might be the one
ultra-stable nucleus that just happened
to kind of go against the odds and stay
carbon 14. so after one half-life if
you're just looking at one atom after
5740 years that's a
you don't know whether this turned into
a nitrogen or this exact atom you just
know that it had a 50 chance of turning
into a nitrogen now if you look at it
over a huge number of atoms i mean if
you start approaching you know
avogadro's number or anything larger i
erase that then all of a sudden you can
use the large large numbers to say okay
on average if each of those atoms must
have had a 50 chance and if i have
gazillions of them half of them will
have turned into nitrogen i don't know
which half but half of them will turn
into it so you might get a question like
i start with uh oh i don't know let's
say i start with
80 grams
of
of something with uh of of let's just
call it x and it has a half-life of
two years i'm just making up this
compound two-year
half-life
half-life and then let's say we go into
a time machine and we look back at our
sample and let's say we only have
10 grams
of our sample left and we want to know
how much time has passed by
so 10 grams left of
x how much time you know x is decaying
the whole time how much time has passed
well let's think about it
we're starting at time zero with 80
grams
after
two years
two years how much are we going to have
left we're going to have 40 grams
so t equals two then after two more
years how many we're gonna have we're
gonna have 20 grams
so this is t equals three oh sorry
that's t equals four years and then
after two more years
two more years
two more i'll only have half of that
left again so now i'm going to have 10
grams left and that's where i am and
this is t equals 6. so if you if you
know you have some compound you're
starting off with 80 grams you know it
has a two year half-life you get in a
time machine and then you you you didn't
build your time machine well you don't
know how well it calibrates against time
but you just look at your compound your
your sample you say only have 10 grams
left you know that
1
one two
three half-lives have gone by and you
could also think about it this way
one-half
to the third power because every time
you have half of your original sample
that's the number of half-lives
after three half-lives you'll have
one-eighth of your original sample and
that's what we have here we have
one-eighth of 80 grams and then and this
is just when you're doing it with a
discrete you know when you're right at
the half-life point and the next video
we're going to explore what if i asked
you a question how many of the particles
or how many grams will you have at
exactly 10 days or at two and a half
years and we'll do that in the next
video